[Música]
eu gostava de começar a perguntar
nesta sala quando você já contrataram um
arquiteto
temos um é para 3 a 3 com plástico
pronto e hoje vou falar um cães abertura
vou falar de cidades mas não tanto na
perspectiva do organismo mais uma
perspectiva de casa do espaço habitado
mas antes mas envolvam em contexto
explicar quem somos de onde viemos e
achou plantamos
somos um time jovem eu sou mais velho
tem final e vamos ainda gravei até os 22
anos sobe 7 trabalhamos no porto e
durante os últimos anos produzimos 150
200 projetos mas para deus pequenas cauê
rotações concurso
estamos numa fase num ponto de viragem
então com tiragem na perspectiva do
próprio clube e que o táxi e tatá ser
confrontado com novos exercícios e do
sítio de onde viemos e para onde vamos a
nossa arquitetura também estatais
alterar por via das condições econômicas
em crise
acreditem ou não para a construção
passou está a viver um momento muito
muito empolgante em termos relativos à
urbana mesmo nova constituição e eu
acredito que como um dos poucos atores
que estabilizou durante o período de
crise vão estar agora numa fase muito
positiva
começamos como quase todos jovens
arquitectos em trabalhos em clientes os
meus pais não tinham dinheiro para mudar
nada para fazer
portanto concurso outros concursos
pequenos projectos uma exposição para
treinar um equipamento temporário por
uma queima das fitas
há algumas limitações é toda a gente
ouve falar de escola que os libaneses
que vem pra cá e compraram os
apartamentos e depois fazem manobras que
nosso trabalho não passa muito pelo
visto nos diz muito crus
o que nós fazemos é transformar isto em
espaço ilimitado sem espaço nos quais o
luxa couro
a experiência de evitar é evitável
espaço os quais nós próprios mas
imaginaríamos a habitar é em muitas
vezes que eu só vou mostrar dois
exemplos
muitas vezes nós ganhamos aquele espaço
como se fosse nosso
isso acontece porque estamos a trabalhar
com o cliente genérico estamos a
trabalhar com que o cliente que nós não
sabemos quem vai ser o investidor
namorou a portanto não se pode dizer
como é que toma o pequeno almoço como é
que vê televisão como costa do euro que
tipo de luz gosta de ter
quando se vai deitar e então acabamos
por especular para criar uma espécie de
narrativa que tem um limite poderia
receber qualquer um dos presentes na
sala e não especificamente o cliente que
nos contratou para este trabalho a à
medida que vamos fazendo este projecto
escola foi aumentando a um apartamento
de 50 metros quadrados ronisson 200 1
200 rolos um prédio em um prédio nos
outros anos em que fomos crescendo
estamos trabalhando com mais corpo mais
primeiro sorriso fomos correndo com
artistas e que temos uma possibilidade
fantástica colaborar com paulina que é
uma artista plástica que faz três amigos
e fazer qualquer coisa que é
extremamente tradicional todos existem
no porto mas nunca usar desta maneira e
este por exemplo o edifício mais recente
que estamos a transformar mas aqui o
cumpriram foi para explicar qual é o meu
papel qual é o nosso papel porque no meu
caso eu sou para um coletivo outro e é
composto por oito pessoas e trabalhamos
no modo mais ou menos horizontal e não
gosto de dizer acho que o tempo do
eduardo souto moura arquiteto pessoas
que atualmente não estamos numa fase
mais mais relaxada quer dizer eu não
sinto necessidade ter meu nome uma porta
acho que não é necessário temos no
treino outra fase
é claro que o meu pai não quer ser visto
mas eu também no horário pronto
e então como é que o nosso papel eu não
sei sinceramente eu estava a ter uma
resposta concreta mas vou usar a técnica
de viva vou fazer uma juntar a frase vou
ver se chegamos a algumas conclusões
a história de casa graça em história que
eu gostava dos contágios e é uma
história começa com um casal muito
simpático tomas iria depois de terem
trabalhado por todo mundo no reino unido
no brasil e na austrália se viram
processar a lisboa
a paixão a sociedade nenhum deus é
português é importante diz ela é
brasileiro
argentina a apaixonar-se por cidade
arranjaram empregos dos quais estavam e
decidiram fixar brant dois anos tiveram
em habitações temporárias casal gavva o
software bianca de tudo e quando se
viram assumir o compromisso de comprar a
casa própria
encontraram um esgoto não é lisboa nem o
porto provavelmente seria o mesmo caso
de 1995 é uma lisboa extremamente
simplificada
o lisbon incluindo o canal tanques da
serra uma vez vão inclusive com
dominante é o tuk tuk mobilizou em que
isto pronto não sei como posso supor que
não consegue ver um mundo fantástico a
ser língua portuguesa é uma disputa que
anuncio desculpa uma lisboa que não é
muito fã do portão da casa oriental
deixou vencer o papel e plástico e as
roupas na nos terminal são as mesmas
desde o fim da opressão produção de
coração e com grande pena minha não é um
espaço fantástico não precisava vai
pegar o sport que o procedimento é e
muito disto tatá será catapultado pelo
visto gols que já toda a gente ouviu
falar que na expectativa de atrair
investimento estrangeiro para o nosso
país acabou por limitar a os preços no
mercado imobiliário e o casal neste caso
thomas teoria a não querem fazer a
dengue não querem fazer um investimento
não querem especular eu só querem
comprar uma casa mas eu perguntei com os
preços que se praticam atualmente os
centros históricos como é que os vai
conseguir parar isto é uma instalação da
última treinar arquitetura três anos
atrás que levantava se pergunta quem é
que vai poder morar em lisboa
quem vai premiar no porto quem vai poder
mudar em coimbra esta cidade estão a ser
provar e pro mal tomadas de assalto e
quando alguém simplesmente quer comprar
um t0 um t1 na baixa e tem um orçamento
normal não estamos a dizer alguém que
não tenha dinheiro tem um orçamento
normal não o consegue fazer
e foi esse o problema que thomas eo nos
colocaram porque é dada altura numa numa
reunião com o agente imobiliário que foi
colocada a hipótese de que vocês têm
pouco dinheiro que a melhor coisa a
fazer é comprar em uma garagem e um
homem de deus
o thomas nos revelou que o bastante a
sério e comprou grande em grande em essa
tinha 200 metros quadrados
mesmo sendo os gols passe fantástico uma
luz natural magnífica 0 janelas portanto
independente de clarabóias muito espaço
muitas idéias muita expectativa e thomas
gols na posição de ser arquiteto porque
eu tinha um espaço
eu tinha a ambição eu tenho o orçamento
para fazer um projecto reabilitação mas
não era o papel eu não sabia o que fazer
com que o portanto uma decisão óbvia a
decisão lógica a decisão correta foi
tomada diretamente com o empreiteiro
como isso aconteceu
passado três dias falou connosco é
portanto eu tentou questionar como é que
era evitar um espaço de se pôr toda a
gente já viu os filmes americanos o oft
prisa aquela aquelas estruturas
industriais que acabam por ser ocupadas
como habitações como o ateliê do pintor
espaços mais ou menos fazem parte do
nosso inconsciente já já os vimos em
tudo em todos os seus filmes não vejo
quem é este é um espaço que eu tenho um
espaço muito grande que é o espaço que o
valor dos carros até chegarem à granja n
uma principal e chegando às 4as e então
qual foi o nosso papel neste caso
específico foi primeiro fazer vários
projetos discutir conversar com menos
perceber o que é que eles querem neste
caso assim como eu estava pequeno almoço
os quais são as rotinas tem carro vamos
50 o trabalho é que elas acordam lavar
os dentes antes ou depois de uma pequena
moça e começamos a fazer várias
propostas precisam que o espaço é um
espaço fantástico
era um espaço com uma luz natural
magnífica apesar não ter uma única
janela e era um espaço em que estavam e
diziam elas de viver tratamento no
planeta e filhos não são portugueses não
têm família em portugal vivem sozinhos
de vez em quando tem um outro amigo
gosta de lá passaram os dias gostoso
estar com meus mas bem lá no fundo vão
viver 95% tempo sozinhos e querem
aproveitar o espaço mas os passos ao
máximo com maior complexidade possível é
e nas suas várias opções com mais
mulheres - mobiliário e divisórias em
vidro com pretos em preto e no final
como uma destas imagens acabaram por se
apaixonar por esta ideia da casa que não
tenha uma única parede tem apenas
uma outra cortina que separavam o espaço
do outro e à medida que fomos
desenvolvendo a desculpa à medida que
fomos desenvolvendo o projeto com muse
que fomos caminhando vamos percebendo
que no final a mulher que os passos que
tínhamos no início não isso sofrer
alterações e apenas receber duas casas
mãe e acaba por se tornar num grande
estúdio num grande espaço de evitar
fizemos as imagens finais discutimos
comuns a questão da cor das ocupações
onde fica a cozinha técnica o quanto nós
fizemos uma casa que era uma um fato à
medida era era que eu tinha de ser
esta casa não vai ser arrendado não vai
ser vendida não é se especulava vai
fazer para 3 2% do mercado imobiliário
em lisboa e como tal é um espaço que era
feito para ele os casa em obras
o nosso papel passa muito por aí também
achei que iria que passa quase 90% por
aí psi como é que sobra como ex passa do
a promover e explicar um cliente que eu
não vai fazer um projeto vai fazer cinco
dez quinze jeckson projeto estruturas um
projecto águas um projeto que vai dizer
e como explicar isto e só teve pessoas
chave é impossível então imagine
explicar o cruzeiro vai ter que pagar
por estas coisas todas não é não é fácil
e então como o jonathan neve costuma
dizer é muito complicado produzir algo
que parece extremamente simples
é muito difícil e os clientes não fazem
idéia de quantos são precisos para a
água como é que faz o isolamento térmico
não sabe muito bem como é que vai
funcionar a iluminação da que vem o
quadro dele disse tadeu
são questões como viável e ninguém pensa
porque nós compramos a casa que o sal eo
carregamento todos ligou quando mas
alguém pensou nisso antes
e neste caso nós temos arquitetos
movimento colaboramos com engenheiros
que tem que fazer esse trabalho e só
assim conseguimos garantir que a obra
fica dessa maneira portanto certa forma
somos uma espécie de mestre
não é não tocar nos mesmos instrumentos
mas temos que conseguir coordenar uma
série de aumentos
e à medida que o projecto foi fluindo
foi como foi sendo construído foram
acontecendo várias visitas à obra que
temos as nossas colaboradoras é fazerem
as inspeções semanais é que tem
na opinião de obra em que imagina esta
foto eu sou do camisola castanha dois
deles são trabalhadores o outro é um
empreiteiro consegue imaginar qual será
o empreiteiro
eu acho que consegue a e mora é uma
infecção constantes são dúvidas são
compromissos e nós conseguimos muitas
vezes no mano uma discussão com o senhor
que tem 40 anos deveria ficar a saber
mais do que um profissional faculdade
mas conseguir ensinar
nós aprendemos a construir quase
exclusivamente quer dizer não
exclusivamente porque tivemos um
professor na faculdade mas quando nos
atiram promove a série mesmo modo nestas
circunstâncias não deixa de ser um
restauro é o rick nash facto temos de
mexer na constituição ea lei que nós
aprendemos é com pessoas como assim o
joão é um ser fantástico que vamos que
vamos aprendendo cada vez mais as
discussões de materiais e das cores que
seja como como fazer o cliente
nacionalidade do cliente estravasar para
próxima própria casa e ver como é que
essas coisas vão acontecendo no espaço à
medida que as amostras do pavimento
enchendo a música que o tudo isso vai
tudo isso vai rematando e que as
fotografias no dia em que o projeto foi
cavado completamente vazia porque não
tinham casa tinha que mudar é que é
preciso momento então havia eu gosto
muito desta foto nunca vivido uma cama e
uma maricá e pronto estamos lá e agora o
que é engraçado é que à medida que o
tempo vai passando cada vez mais a um
vaso é um gato a um sofá a uma mesa e
estará exposta não há presa a uma grande
complexidade em que todas as cortinas
estiverem fechadas temos quatro espaços
pequenos tiveram todas abertas temos tão
grande espaço de 11 a e treinar lisboa
jaime essa pedra projeto ficam nos
amostral na no pantanal sé em julho a
equipe nosso papel foi uma vez mais
explicar a um público que geralmente não
trabalha com arquitetos que geralmente
distantes da profissão o que aconteceu o
i e é engraçado ver da manhã as pessoas
querem colocar um cocar duvidosa que
editamos entrar no armazém sem janelas é
uma granja
mas a serem lá mais convencidos e
daremos oportunidade explicar a rádio e
na televisão
amanhã é quem quiser saber o que nós
podemos fazer e como é que nós enquanto
arquitetos podemos aproximar o público
da construção como é que nós podemos
explicar o que nós podemos fazer e eu
vou pagar os amarrando plataforma para
isso e para as curiosidades para
tentarmos explicar aos clientes o que os
cães não os convidados do que o que
aconteceu e finalmente casa habitada
a casa foi terminado em junho o tomas
iria tomar o poder portanto agora a casa
deles nós saltamos fora mas é com grande
prazer que semanalmente os 15 em 15 dias
nos mandam imel do novo quarteto que
compraram na nova carreira e esta casa
mais 1 mil da fachada mais o meu podem
encontrar em lisboa só o portão não tem
mais nada até fachada toda a casa passa
completamente expressiva ea vida que o
tempo vai passando é é bonito para nós
enquanto arquiteto sentir que pela
primeira vez nós estamos a trabalhar com
uns espectadores
estamos a trabalhar com alguém que que
ama o espaço que evite que de cada vez
que vamos nos 110 a 10 quase por essa
relação tão íntima que fomos tendo e
também é bonito para nós ver como é que
os vão imaginando espaço como é que eu
uso vão ocupando as peças com comprando
ea imaginação com que eu uso o viton e é
é fantástico para nós perceber que tudo
bem não é um projeto adicional não é uma
casa não é um t3 não é um não tem placa
são essas coisas que dizem mas é é um
espaço queimava é um espaço que dá
prazer alguém e vemos imenso prazer
enorme poder imaginar entre isto e mais
30 na baixa isto é muito melhor está
muito melhor fazer mas sabemos ainda
melhor sentido que teve escola vamos que
há uma paixão que não está pelos passos
que apenas existe por conta de facto um
fato feito à medida de quem tá ocupam a
e proteína como eu disse eu da primeira
vez que ela foi isso agora só falta o
gato tem que aparecer o quarto porque
está fazendo falta é e eles disseram que
até pode faltar mais qualquer coisa está
uma casa garagem
e toda a gente usa um carro portanto há
tantas vezes fazemos a piada com os
clientes adoram usar o carro pra cama e
se possível não querem na garagem querem
ver diretamente com o papa cama aqui
podem dar para fazer isso até para
trazer três ou quatro portanto é
perfeitamente possível
é esta a ideia é compreensível e
louvável limites em que a garagem o
quarto casas vine cozinhas ao acabam por
ser todos uns passar a e esta imagem a
imagem é a última imagem é minha imagem
preferida porque não sabemos nem do que
se trata é um espaço branco tem nota
sobre um canto do sofá no flex vezes que
é um carro a uma cama a um vaso uma
cortina seja tão aqui todos os
ingredientes foram usados no projeto sem
um deus sustentar qualquer tipo de
supremacia relativamente a substância é
uma casa que vai crescer naturalmente
cândida que for sendo habitada e ocupada
vai ganhar outros outros atributos mas
acima de tudo é é uma casa que apesar de
não deixar de ser uma garagem é cada dia
que passa a cada nova peça a casa
cada saco de compras que entra pela
porta é mais casas do que 9 entre o
obrigavam 1
[Música]
[Aplausos]